the holiday season can be ludicrous
although this year it's doubly true
because Disney plus is releasing dashing
through the snow a holiday movie
Spectacular starring you guessed it
Chris ludicrous Bridges the rapper SL
actor is joined by Lil R howy and a
great Supporting Cast to give us a new
and hilarious looking take on the tale
of Santa Claus magically showing up in
real life so I thought I'd get in the
Christmas spirit and go through what we
know so far about this upcoming holiday
ROM so what's dashing through the snow
all about well like all good Christmas
movies it has a character who has
decided that Christmas isn't for them
and while our protagonist isn't at
Grinch level of hate when it comes to
the holiday he's definitely not looking
to Carol around and trim a tree anytime
soon Chris Bridges whom I really want to
refer to as Luda but I won't in the name
of professionalism plays Eddie Garrick
Eddie had some sort of event when he was
a kid that traumatized him for all
things Christmas so while he's
definitely not written as a scrooge or
other kind of bad dude he's clearly
putting out negative Vibes as the
holiday approaches Eddie's wife asks him
to look after their daughter on
Christmas Eve so she accompanies him to
his work as a social worker see he's a
good dude while working the two
encounter Lil Real's character Nick and
it looks like it's a bit unclear if Nick
is you know that Nick the one with the
saint in front of his name or perhaps
he's just a guy named Nick who is we'll
say accent to be kind though given that
it's a Disney Christmas movie I'd put my
money on him being Santa who knows over
the course of the movie the trio ends up
angering a local politician who sends
henchmen after them and of course
magical exus themed chaos ensues and
maybe just maybe the experience will
turn Eddie into a believer in The Wonder
of Christmas again one thing that sets
this movie apart from many of the
traditional Christmas movies we've seen
is that it's a cast full of people of
color CH Bridges and Lil real Howry are
both firmly established as prominent
black entertainers so it's not only
exciting to see them working together
but as co-leads in a major project like
this and bridges his wife and daughter
are played by Tiana Paris and Madison
Sky validum respectively who are both
people of color it's a refreshing change
of pace from the usual White Christmas
we see and on top of that the director
Tim story is black as well from the
trailer however it appears the movie is
being marketed equally to all audiences
you just have to like Christmas movies
duh so that's also a great thing to see
it's far from Tim story's first time
behind the camera for a major project
though it's a decidedly new genre for
him he's a Hollywood veteran when it
comes to helming great movies getting
his starred in films by directing the
comedy Classic Barber Shop that was
after spending half a decade honing his
skills as a music video director and
since then he's been behind the camera
for a slew of great movies from Fant
Fantastic Four to ride along to the
recent horror comedy the blackening so
clearly the movie is in good hands
though Tim did admit that when he found
out he was working with Disney it
definitely made him nervous it's his
first time working with the mouse house
and he was keenly aware of its
importance in terms of society culture
and the holidays in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly he talked about how
it's always been his goal to create
entertaining content that appeals to
both adults and teens but at the same
time he had hadn't really done any
movies aimed at including little kids in
the demographic so that was daunting for
starters but then he also realized how
important it was not to mess up his big
chance with Disney and to represent the
brand in the best light so he made sure
to dial everything up when it came to
the visual aspects said Tim quote
anytime I was able to decorate a room or
a place it's Disney so you also try to
take it just a little bit farther than
maybe it would go elsewhere in that same
interview story talked about how
impressed he was with the chemistry
between Chris Bridges and Lil Ral
obviously the two come from different
backgrounds and entertainment with Luda
Chris starting as a rap Mega star and
Lil real as a comedian and actor but
story found that they jelled immediately
and worked off of each other brilliantly
he said they not only allowed for space
for each other which brought out
excellent performances from both of them
but they also found the balance of
playing their characters in a grounded
manner while still allowing the magic
and Whimsy of a Disney film to come
through story added quote I got very
lucky that they both were willing and
able to do it rounding out the main Trio
in the movie is Madison Sky validum who
plays Eddie's daughter but apparently
the filming schedule was really tricky
for her as in she literally couldn't be
there for a lot of the filming I'm
assuming it had to do with school either
way it meant that Lil R and Chris
Bridges had to do a lot of their scenes
acting to an empty space then Madison
came in later and filmed her parts and
they added her to the scenes in post
production Tim story was thoroughly
impressed with how well both of them
handled this rather odd scenario though
he did also mention what a positive
effect Madison had on the set when she
was able to be there especially because
she was always excited and happy to be
there and her happiness made it a lot
easier for the cast and crew to stay
positive he added quote you would see
her eyes go big when she saw certain
things she always brought that spirit
and she reminded you constantly what you
were doing the movie comes out on Disney
Plus on November 17th giving you plenty
of time to catch it and ramp up your
holiday cheer in addition to the cast I
mentioned it also has a great Supporting
Cast including comedy veterans like
Oscar Nunes Marilyn rice scub ravie V
Patel and Kevin Connelly so now that you
know it's going to be a ludicrous
holiday season you can start planning
today well actually the only new plans
you need to make might just be leaving
time to watch dashing through the snow
otherwise you can just do what you
usually do which if you're anything like
me means gaining 10 lb and then blaming
it on the cold who's with me have any
thoughts about dashing through the snow
pop them in the comments section